who is ready to fall for a farmer
can I tell my mom that I was coming here
she said girl you don't like the dirt
what you doing but I do think love is
worth this opportunity my mom will like
her my mom would love her I come from
Orlando Florida and it's very much a
hookup culture so I'm here to meet my
person are you ready for this I'm here
for the right reason just see how you
feel it's really hit me in the heart
like this is real move over Bachelor
Farmer wants a wife yeah that's right
more than one farmer that is four hunky
Cowboys are looking to lasso a life
partner and 32 women are vying for their
heart okay so it's based off a British
version of this show now they tried it
back in the U.S in 2008 but it didn't
really take off so let's see how it goes
this time around and hey maybe host
country singer Jennifer Nettles will be
the good luck charm yeah okay I listen
I'm a huge you're a huge Yellowstone fan
so I think men and horses beautiful
combinate combination combination yeah
um would you date a farmer oh I listen
Farm life is tough they wake up very
early to do those chores I'm currently
dating somebody who grew up on a farm
it's just too much responsibility for me
oh I'm online wrangler's on the chair
they can wake up early I'll just stay
asleep it's fine do you plan on dating
John Dutton from Yellowstone if I wasn't
married maybe I love farmers and small
town like listen there's nothing wrong
with that do cowboy boots do it for you
yes
[Music]